hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
stellt heute den Gesetzentwurf zur
Cannabis Legalisierung vor da haben
viele drauf gewartet den hat das
Kabinett heute morgen schon beschlossen
er muss jetzt nur noch in den Bundestag
ja und wir fragen uns alle was steht
jetzt drin im Entwurf und da wollen wir
heute gemeinsam live drauf gucken auf
die Pressekonferenz unsere
Spiekermann die ist auch vor Ort und sie
hat eine der Fragen weil sich die ihr am
meisten stellt in unseren Chats nämlich
wird sich auch etwas am THC Grenzwert im
Straßenverkehr ändern all diese Fragen
zum Entwurf und all eure Fragen ordnen
wir heute vor und nach der
Pressekonferenz ein und das tun wir
gemeinsam mit unserer Hauptstadt
Christiane hübscher mit ZDF
Rechtsexperte Jan Henrich und später
spreche ich auch noch mit Professor
Stefan tönis er ist Vorsitzender der
grenzwertkommission der Bundesregierung
und dafür brauche ich aber wie immer
eure Fragen und Kommentare zum Thema
schreibt sie gerne wie immer hier in den
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an die
Adresse die ihr jetzt eingeblendet seht
jetzt schalte ich aber erstmal zu meiner
Kollegin Christiane hübscher die uns aus
Berlin live zugeschaltet das hallo
Christiane hallo Viktoria grüß Dich
Christiane mit welchen Erwartungen guckt
man denn heute auf diese Pressekonferenz
und Pressekonferenz und auf diesen
Gesetzentwurf das Thema wird ja jetzt
seit einigen Monaten ziemlich kontrovers
diskutiert ja das kann man sagen die
Erwartungen sind groß denke ich der
Widerstand ist auch groß den man seit
ein paar Tagen und heute ganz speziell
natürlich noch mal vernimmt das ist ja
auch ein großes Gesetz ein
Paradigmenwechsel möchte ich sagen das
sieht man schon allein daran dass der
erste Gesetzentwurf den äh also die
Eckpunkte die Karl Lauterbach mal
vorgestellt hat der war gerade mal 64
Seiten lang und jetzt reden wir über 160
Seiten also daran sieht man schon es ist
kompliziert ähm das ist heute das
Kabinett beschlossen hat ist jetzt
erstmal nur der erste Schritt das Gesetz
muss dann noch in den Bundestag und auch
in den Bundesrat obwohl es nicht
zustimmungspflichtig ist da sind aber
natürlich noch Änderungen zu erwarten an
den Streitpunkten die ich schon
angesprochen habe sieht man schon so ein
bisschen das ist kein gewinnerthema mehr
dieses Thema teilweise Cannabis
Legalisierung so wie es vielleicht noch
war im Zuge der Koalitionsverhandlungen
und als der Koalitionsvertrag
abgeschlossen wurde und ja sehr auf
Druck der JuLis und der Grünen vor allem
der Grünen Jugend da rein verhandelt
wurde dass man eben Cannabis teilweise
freigeben möchte damals war das so ein
so eine Sache damit konnte man sich
wunderbar beliebt machen weil gerade
jungen Wählern diese Zeit entscheiden
vorbei denn wie gesagt es gibt jetzt im
Zuge der gesetzesfindungen eben doch
viel Diskussion
ja so viel zu politischen Diskussionen
was genau im Gesetzentwurf drin steht
das hat sich mein Kollege Pablo sie lala
hier schon für uns angeschaut
Cannabis seit Jahrhunderten ein
Rauschmittel und in Deutschland bislang
illegale Droge jetzt soll kiffen
teilweise erlaubt werden genauer der
Besitz von maximal 25 Gramm genauso der
Anbau von drei Pflanzen zum Eigenkonsum
der Bezug soll in sogenannten Cannabis
social Clubs möglich sein die
verzeichnen seit bekannt werden der
Pläne regen Zulauf sie sollen ganz
genauen Regeln unterliegen nur
Mitglieder dürfen höchstens 50 g pro
Monat erwerben 500 Mitglieder darf ein
Club haben und die Abgabe darf nicht in
der Nähe von Schulen oder Kitas erfolgen
heißt in der Praxis Cannabis Clubs bauen
die Pflanzen an und geben sie an ihre
Mitglieder ab ursprünglich hatte die
Ampel noch viel weitreichende Pläne im
Koalitionsvertrag kündigte sie eine
kontrollierte Abgabe von Cannabis an
Erwachsene zu genusszwecken in
lizenzierten Geschäften an doch es gab
Europa rechtliche Bedenken auch am
Gesetz wie es jetzt geplant es gibt es
heftige Kritik zum Beispiel aus der CDU
und aus einigen Bundesländern
ja und mit uns hier ist jetzt auch ZDF
Rechtsexperte Jan Hinrich hallo Jan
hallo wir haben es ja gerade in dem
Stück gehört der Gesetzentwurf geht
inhaltlich doch nicht so weit wie
ursprünglich mal geplant kannst du uns
erklären woran das liegt das liegt vor
allen Dingen an rechtlichen Hürden die
in der ursprünglichen Planung
entgegenstehen zumindest mal viele
Fragen sind da offen wie die
ursprünglich geplanten Vorschläge
vereinbar werden mit EU-Recht und
Völkerrecht
im Koalitionsvertrag stand ja auch mal
drin dass tatsächlich der Verkauf von
Cannabis in lizenzierten Shops
ermöglicht werden soll und da ist es
relativ deutlich dass das eventuell
scheitern könnte die größte Hürde ist da
dass EU Recht da gibt es einen
Rahmenbeschluss von 2004 der eben besagt
der alle Mitgliedstaaten der EU
verpflichtet ähm strafrechtlich gegen
besitzt gegen Handel von Cannabis von
Drogen im allgemeinen Cannabis explizit
auch vorzugehen und
dagegen da gibt es nur relativ wenige
Ausnahmen die möglich sind also diese
dieser Rahmenbeschluss sieht nur
Ausnahmen für die Regelung von
Privatkonsum vor und genau das
versucht man jetzt eben in einem ersten
Schritt zu ermöglichen diese erste Säule
die heute vorgestellt wird eben die
Entkriminalisierung von Besitz die ein
Kriminalisierung von privatem Anbau von
bis zu drei Pflanzen und eben die
Entkriminalisierung von nicht
kommerziellen gemeinschaftlichen Anbau
in diesen Cannabis Clubs man versucht
sich sozusagen Ranzen diese zweite Säule
also der Verkauf in eventuellen
modellstädten die wird dann noch mal ein
bisschen
komplizierter da gibt's Stimmen die
sagen das könnte Europa rechtswidrig
sein deswegen will das Bundesministerium
diesen Vorschlag erstmal später angehen
und auch erstmal in Brüssel vorlegen zur
Prüfung damit es eben nicht noch mal
sozusagen einen Maut Desaster gibt ja
Thema cannabisclubs das wird ja auch in
den letzten Wochen sehr viel besprochen
gibt's denn da schon Beispiele irgendwo
in der EU wo das läuft und auch klappt
die Beispiele gibt in Teilen von Spanien
in einzelnen Regionen wird das schon
gehandhabt da ist es aber nicht
sozusagen für ganz Spanien gesetzlich
geregelt seit neuestem ist es auch in
Malta geregelt dass dort solche
Cannabis-Clubs tatsächlich ähnlich wie
der deutsche Vorschlag jetzt ist erlaubt
sind
endgültig geklärt ist die Frage ob das
erlaubt ist vom Europäischen Gerichtshof
der das letztendlich entscheiden müsste
noch nicht aber zumindest mal gibt es
diese Beispiele und bis jetzt ist noch
niemand eingeschnitten
okay also Gerichtsurteile die vielleicht
auch noch ausstehen wir haben hier
direkt schon eine Frage aus der
Community an Dich hier fragt jemand eine
weitere Frage ist warum man die
Entkriminalisierung für ländersachen
macht jedes Bundesland wird anders
entscheiden der Norden wird social Clubs
erlauben Bayern zum Beispiel verweigern
und verbieten was sagst du dazu also das
Gesetz das heute vorgestellt wird ist
erstmal ein Bundesgesetz und das regelt
die Strafbarkeit und die erlaubte
Nutzung und den erlaubten Konsum von
Cannabis und das gilt erstmal in allen
Bundesländern wenn es dann durch den
Bundestag geht das heißt das ist erstmal
nicht Ländersache
Betäubungsmittel Recht und Strafrecht
ist auch erstmal Bundessache aber wie
genau die Verfolgung wie genau die
Ausgestaltung aussieht das müssen dann
die Länder entscheiden aber
grundsätzlich gibt's dieses Problem
erstmal bei dem heutigen Gesetz nicht
ja und wir sehen gerade schon im
Livebild Herr Lauterbach setzt sich wir
schalten jetzt also live rüber zu
verkaufen eure Fragen danach noch
ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hier vorne Platz zu nehmen
begrüße sie zu der Bundespressekonferenz
mit dem Bundesminister für Gesundheit
Professor Dr Karl Lauterbach zum
cannabis-gesetz 1
kommt direkt aus dem Kabinett Herr
Minister
vielen Dank Herr Feldhoff erneut danke
dass wir hier in Ihren Räumen vortragen
dürfen wir haben eben im Kabinett das
cannabis-gesetz beschlossen und ich bin
froh dass das also erreicht werden
konnte es ist ein wichtiges Gesetz
welches also eine langfristige
Wände in der deutschen Drogenpolitik
darstellen wird das Gesetz geht im
Prinzip auf drei bestehende und nicht
gelöste Probleme ein das erste Problem
ist wir haben steigenden Cannabiskonsum
das betrifft leider auch Kinder und
Jugendliche junge Erwachsene das heißt
der steigende Konsum findet derzeit
statt ohne dass es darauf eine Antwort
gäbe das geht für viele Bundesländer
eigentlich für alle Bundesländer auch
insbesondere zum Beispiel auch für
Bayern wir haben eine
umfängliche und auch zunehmende
Drogenkriminalität mittlerweile machen
die Cannabis Delikte 50 Prozent der
Drogenkriminalität in Deutschland aus
das Problem der Drogenkriminalität
betrifft diejenigen die hier verurteilt
werden betrifft aber auch also die
gesamte Beschaffungskriminalität und die
Gewinne die mit der Drogenkriminalität
erwirtschaftet werden die dann genutzt
werden können für andere Delikte auch
für andere Drogendelikte und schließlich
haben wir einen großen Schwarzmarkt der
zunehmend problematisch ist in dem die
Cannabisprodukte immer häufiger auch
toxische beinengungen aufweisen oder
toxische
Dosierungen der Cannabiskonsum von heute
hat wenig mit dem Cannabis Konsum von
vor 30 Jahren zu tun wir haben deutlich
höhere Konzentrationen von THC wir haben
bei meningungen und wir haben auch
Streckungen die bedenklich sind und
somit die drei Probleme sind ungelöst
und es gibt kein Konzept das Konzept was
wir hier vorlegen ist ein Konzept der
kontrollierten Legalisierung es wird aus
zwei Seiten kritisiert es wird zum einen
kritisiert von der Seite derjenigen die
sich eine vollständigere Legalisierung
gewünscht hätte oder wünschen
weil dort argumentiert wird das
Verfahren ist so nicht weitgehend genug
oder noch zu bürokratisch wir wollen
eine komplette Legalisierung
umfänglicher und dann gibt es auch die
Kritik derer die sagen der
Illegalisierung ist ein Schild in die
falsche Richtung so hätte man das gar
nicht machen müssen somit eine Kritik
von beiden Seiten das ist oft für ein
Gesetz ein schlechtes Zeichen wenn es
von zwei Seiten kritisiert wird es ist
aber manchmal auch ein gutes Zeichen und
das ist hier der Fall dass man sich die
Tatsache dass es von beiden Seiten
angegriffen wird ist ein gutes Zeichen
weil die einer Lösung die Freigabe mit
viel spezielle Liberalisierung wie
beispielsweise in Holland oder in
einigen amerikanischen Bundesstaaten der
hätte einfach dazu geführt dass der
Konsum ausgedehnt worden wäre und das
wollen wir ja genau nicht wir wollen den
Konsum begrenzen und sicherer machen
insbesondere für Kinder und Jugendliche
wir wollen aber nicht ausdehnen somit
diejenigen die sagen wir wollen dort
weitergehen wir brauchen mehr
Liberalisierung die nehmen in Kauf dass
dann tatsächlich der damit verbundene
entweder kommerzielle Druck konnte in
den Vereinigten Staaten der
kommerziellen Cannabis Anbau und
Angebote mehr Konsum oder dass ich einen
Schwarzmarkt habe wie in Holland das ist
was wir nicht wollen diejenigen die
sagen die Legalisierung ist schon ein
Schritt in die falsche Richtung das
hätte man nie machen sollen die haben
keine Antwort auf die drei Probleme die
ich gerade beschrieben habe wir haben
keine Antwort auf das Problem der Konsum
steigt ja er wird ja nicht von uns
geschaffen die Drogenkriminalität läuft
auch und der Schwarzmarkt ist ebenfalls
wachsend und die toxischen Substanzen
hatte ich ja schon erwähnt somit die
Tatsache dass wir ein Gesetz machen was
mit Augenmaß funktioniert ist ein
Zeichen dass ein gutes Gesetz ist die
Legalisierung sieht zunächst einmal vor
dass wir den Kinder und Jugendschutz
aber auch den Schutz junge Erwachsener
sehr ernst nehmen daher bleibt die
Legalisierung natürlich ausgeschlossen
für Kinder und Jugendliche und wenn
Kinder und Jugendliche konsumieren dann
gibt es erstmalig auch umfängliche
Präventionsprogramme und bei
problematischen konsumen kommen sogar
die Jugendämter ins Spiel das heißt der
Kinder und jugendschutz wird ausgedehnt
und bei Kindern und Jugendlichen und bei
Erwachsenen arbeiten wir mit einer
Kampagne wo wir das zentrale Problem
beim Konsum noch mal in den Vordergrund
stellen für Kinder Jugendliche aber
junge Erwachsene dass tatsächlich im
Alter bis 25 das wachsende Gehirn von
dem Konsum oft nachhaltig beschädigt
wird darauf müssen wir Hinweisen zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt ist das ein Tabuthema
darüber wird wenig gesprochen das spielt
in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung von
Cannabiskonsum derzeit kaum eine Rolle
aber wenn wir dieses Gesetz
durchgebracht haben und wenn wir die
Cannabis also Kampagne geben gezeigt
haben die ich gleich noch etwas sagen
werde wird jeder junge Mensch wissen
wenn ich Cannabis konsumiere wenn ich
das regelmäßig tue dann beschädige ich
dort mein Gehirn ich habe dann die
erhöhte Wahrscheinlichkeit später zu
stoßen zu entwickeln ich kann an
Aufmerksamkeitsstörungen erkranken die
möglicherweise nicht reversibel sind ich
kann darüber hinaus auch Veränderungen
im Gehirn haben die mich für andere
Drogen also seiner vorbereiten sucht
afinger machen all diese Dinge werden am
Ende des Gesetzgebungsverfahrens jeden
bekann wir werden daher bei Kindern und
Jugendlichen auch bei jungen Erwachsenen
eine ganz andere Aufmerksamkeit für die
schädliche Wirkung von Cannabis in der
Altersgruppe insbesondere der unter
25-Jährigen haben das gesamte Thema wird
end tabuisiert und die Tatsache dass
jetzt zum Beispiel über diese Schäden
viel gesprochen wird wirkt ja schon
Debatte findet schon statt daher finde
ich auch die Diskussion um das Gesetz
die ihr Kontroverse ist nicht schwierig
sondern hilfreich weil in dieser Debatte
werden ja erstmalig auch die wichtigen
Probleme das Cannabiskonsums offen
ausgetragen ich begrüße daher die
kontroverse Diskussion um dieses Gesetz
ausdrücklich es ist eine Wende in der
Drogenpolitik wir entkriminalisieren wir
machen das aber auf einer Art und Weise
wo eigentlich nur der privater eigenen
Anbau erlaubt wird wo der eigenen Konsum
erlaubt wird wo die der besitzt mit bis
zu 25 kam Cannabis zukünftig strafbar
ist das Konstrukt der
anbauvereine oder Genossenschaften ist
ein gutes Konstrukt denn wenn diese
anbauvereine und Genossenschaften für
die Mitglieder des Cannabis konsumieren
produzieren und die dann auch
konsumieren dann ist damit zu rechnen
dass die Preise die eben dort entstehen
was doch relativ wenig reglementiert ist
dass diese Preise sehr kompetitiv sind
wahrscheinlich niedriger liegen werden
als auf dem Schwarzwald wir glauben
daher dass du den Schwarzmarkt mit
dieser Regelung gut zurückdrängen können
das ist eine andere Regelung als wenn
ich sage es wird legalisiert aber ich
verlasse mich darauf dass die Produktion
einfach aus dem Schwarzwald oder woher
auch immer kommt oder dass ich das
kommerzialisiere wie in den Vereinigten
Staaten dieses genossenschaftsprinzip
wird zum zu eigenen Kosten relativ
preiswert
qualitätsgesichert Cannabis Produkte zur
Verfügung stellen und wird den
Schwarzmarkt deutlich zurück
wir haben Schutzzonen um die
cannabisanbauvereinigungen herum 200
Meter Abstand müssen eingehalten werden
für den konsumkonsumverbot konsumverbot
um Schulen herum 200 Meter um Kinder und
Jugendeinrichtungen um Kinder
Spielplätze herum um öffentlich
zugängliche Sportstätten das heißt es
wird jeder begreifen kann an sich ist
Konsum hat nichts zu suchen bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen bleibt dort verboten
enge gesetzliche Rahmenbedingungen sind
geschaffen worden da wird oft
argumentiert dass das bürokratisch sein
ich kann ohne bestimmte Regeln keinen
Kinder und Jugendschutz betreiben das
ist da nicht möglich dann bin ich in
einer Liberalisierung wo ich sage ich
kümmere mich nicht darum aber bestimmte
Regeln müssen hier eingehalten werden
und das haben wir also hier gemacht ich
teile daher auch nicht die Befürchtungen
zum Beispiel das Richterbundes dass die
also
aufwendige Verfolgung von kleinen Drogen
cannabis-delikten dass das nicht
zurückgehen würde sondern sehr ganz klar
wenn 25 Gramm besitzt strafreise legal
sind wenn das Ganze aus dem
Betäubungsmittelgesetz herausgenommen
wird wenn es so ist dass der Anbau
nachvollzogen werden kann die
Mitgliedschaft kann geprüft werden dann
gibt es natürlich sehr viel mehr Konsum
der schlicht unbedenklich ist aus
rechtlicher Perspektive Perspektive und
wenn der Schwarzmarkt dann
zurückgedrängt wird dann wird auch diese
große Verfolgung von also in Mengen
großen Mengen Cannabis die reinkommen
das wird dann hoffentlich weniger werden
ich glaube dass es uns hier schnell
gelingen wird dass der Anteil des legal
also konsumierten Cannabis viel größer
ist als der cannabisanteil der illegal
eingeführt wurde und der dann konsumiert
wird davon gehe ich aus
insgesamt aus meiner Sicht ein
Gesetz mit Augenmaß und wir haben uns
hier entschieden bereits zum Zeitpunkt
der Kabinetts Befassung unsere Kampagne
vorzustellen Kampagne die sich
insbesondere an junge Menschen wendet
die in den sozialen Medien insbesondere
aufgespielt werden soll und womit wir
junge Leute so erreichen wollen dass
junge Leute einfach erfahren was das
zentrale Problem hier wenn ich früher
anfangen kann er bis zu konsumieren dann
kann ich zum Beispiel eine Angststörung
entwickeln oder dann kann ich durch die
Aufmerksamkeitsstörungen die sich dann
oft ausbilden kann es sein dass ich kann
so gutes Abitur oder vielleicht gar kein
Abitur machen oder kann es sein dass ich
mit dem Studium nicht klar komme dass
ich dort überfordert bin und daher sind
diese Sprüche die wir dort bringen die
Klingen zunächst einmal locker und
salopp das sind aber die genau die
Sprüche die rüberbringen dass ich damit
tatsächlich
deinem Gehirn einen Schaden zufügen kann
wenn ich zu früh mit dem Cannabiskonsum
beginne oder gar problematisch
konsumiere ich glaube das wird am Ende
dieser Gesetzgebung wird das jeder
wissen ich gehe daher davon aus dass das
eine bessere Einführung ist als in
vielen anderen Ländern und der Fehler
gemacht wurde dass man das zu sehr
betrachtet hat als eine
Weiterentwicklung im Sinne einer
liberaleren Konsumgesellschaft das ist
auch ganz wichtig ob stelle ich das auch
heute vor für das Kabinett die waren ja
zahlreiche Ressorts beteiligt ich stelle
das vorder das gleichzeitig in
Deutschland auch eine
gesundheitspolitische Entscheidung ist
weil mit den jetzigen Verfahren können
wir den Kinder und Jugendschutz nicht
ernsthaft betreiben das Thema ist
tabuisiert wir haben steigenden Konsum
problematischen Konsum so hätte es
einfach nicht weitergehen können und
daher ist das ein wichtiger Wendepunkt
in unserer Drogenpolitik vielen Dank
Herr Minister ich habe jetzt schon 15
Wortmeldungen und ich hoffe dass wir mit
kurzen Fragen und relativ schnellen
Antworten die erste Frage geht an Frau
ich würde gerne wissen wie sehen Sie
denn Cannabis am Steuer Herr Wissing
sagt der Minister Wissing sagte brauchen
klare Regeln ähnlich wie beim Alkohol
kann aber es ist auf einem Blut länger
nachweisbar also welchen THC Gehalt
welcher wäre da sozusagen geeignet
welche Regelungen sehen Sie was Cannabis
betrifft im Straßenverkehr
ich stimme verkehrs- und digitalminister
Wissing zu dass wir hier Grenzwerte
benötigen diese Grenzwerte werden
derzeit wissenschaftlich vorbereitet
unter der Leitung von Herrn Wissing und
diese Grenzwerte werden dann auch
umgesetzt werden aber es muss eine
belastbaren Grenzwert geben ähnlich wie
beim Alkohol und somit also sind wir da
auf dem Weg auf den wir immer unterwegs
sind dass wir uns zunächst einmal an der
Studienlage orientieren und dann einen
entsprechenden Empfehlung machen
der Kollege
von der Apotheken Umschau ich wollte mal
fragen woher denn die Gelder für den
Jugendschutz kommen beim Tabak gibt es
eine Tabaksteuer Alkohol haben wir auch
ist das irgendwie hoch sind denn die
Gelder wenn es jetzt nicht von den
Steuern herkommen danke
die Mittel für die Kampagne stehen ja
bereits zunächst einmal diese Kampagne
die wir heute vorstellen die wird sehr
schnell starten ist etatisiert darüber
hinaus also haben wir noch zahlreiche
andere Maßnahmen zum Beispiel Kampagnen
durch die Bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche Aufklärung in bewährter
Qualität wir werden auch eine sogenannte
Landing Page dort vorbereiten das heißt
eine also
Website wo man alle Fragen zum Cannabis
dann für sich selbst beantwortet sieht
oder wo auch Eltern nachlesen können für
gefährdete Kinder Jugendliche wo wir
Aufklärungsmaterial haben wo diese
Studien die ich eben beschrieben habe
lesbar sind das ist eine gute Kampagne
werden unsere jetzige attack-kampagne
die über den gesamten Herbst durchlaufen
wird die insbesondere in den sozialen
Medien aufspielt dann wird die
Bundeszentrale gesundheitliche
Aufklärung kommt das wäre etatisiert
sein und darüber hinaus eben die
Landingpage
aber woher kommt das Geld aus Ihrem
Budget dann es werden wir so aus den aus
dem Haushalt werden wir das beschreiben
so weit ist kann nur so viel seines Geld
wird da sein und
mehr muss nicht gesagt sein
ja Herr Lauterbach der ökonomi Justus
haucup auf den sie sich auch berufen
haben in der beim Gesetzentwurf hat
gesagt er kann keine Logik daran
erkennen dass die Clubs eine Obergrenze
von 500 Mitgliedern haben
und er argumentiert dann auch mit den
Größenvorteilen und skalierungseffekten
sie haben auch schon gesagt sie muss ja
sein kompetitiv zum Schwarzmarktpreis
warum haben Sie sich für 500 Mitglieder
als Obergrenze entschieden bei den Clubs
ja wir haben natürlich mehr als einen
Experten zu Rate gezogen und haben uns
auch zum Beispiel die Frage gestellt
wenn das Clubs sind in dieser
Größenordnung ist dann zu erwarten dass
der Preis zu dem produziert und
abgegeben werden kann ist der überhaupt
konkurrenzfähig zum Schwarzmarktpreis
kommt der unter den Schwarzmarktpreis
was er sinnvoll wäre sonst habe ich ja
der Preiskämpfe zu Lasten des legal
beantworten kann ist und da sind wir zu
dem Ergebnis gekommen dass diese
klubgröße noch gut überschaubar ist dass
ich auch kontrollieren kann sind die
Mitglieder alle 18 sind die Mitglieder
hatten sich an die Regeln und so weiter
und so fort somit ist das eine
Optimierungsaufgabe sie müssen Clubs
haben der eine gewisse Größe haben sonst
ist das Cannabis Produkt nachher zu
teuer wenn die Clubs zu klein sind oder
wenn Sie zum Beispiel den Anbau das
haben wir noch mal verändert also nur am
Club zulassen worden dann haben sie
nachher wenig und teures Cannabis das
will niemand somit muss man die Größe
skalieren aber die Clubs dürfen nicht so
groß werden dass eine tatsächliche
Kontrolle des Kinder und Jugendschutzes
der uns ja so wichtig ist nicht mehr
möglich ist
ja kurze Nachfrage wenn wenn ich wenn
man sich für den Personen Club anmeldet
dann gibt man sein Personalausweis ab
ist Mitglied des Clubs damit das doch
eigentlich Jugendschutz gewährleistet
also ob das jetzt für
ist jetzt 5000 Mitglieder dort 500 sind
es ist ja eigentlich es kann ja nur
Mitglied werden wer nachweisen kann dass
er über 18 ist es gibt ja zahlreiche
Grundsätze die hier also kontrolliert
werden müssen zum Beispiel ist der THC
Wert also für die unter
21-Jährigen niedrig genug da haben wir
ja die zehnte zehn Prozentwert also
durchgesetzt um dort also die jungen
Leute besser zu schützen ist es
gewährleistet dass tatsächlich pro Monat
nicht mehr als 50 Gramm abgesetzt werden
oder 30 Gramm bei den unter 21-Jährigen
es muss einen präventionsbeauftragten es
gibt eine Reihe von Regeln die beachtet
werden wir haben das übrigens auf das
Notwendige Maße reduziert also es wird
ja oft kritisiert der ganze Vorgang wäre
zu bürokratisch aber wir haben es
wirklich auf das konzentriert was wir
dringend kontrollieren müssen um den
also um die Qualität darzustellen aber
auch den Kinder und Jugendschutz und den
Schutz junge Erwachsene sicherstellen
Herr Lauterbach warum haben Sie sich für
die Besitz über Grenze von 25 Gramm und
pro Monat 50 Gramm entschieden denn es
gibt ja Kritik die da lautet dass diese
Mengen zu regelmäßigen Konsum einladen
also was ist da die Begründung für diese
Menge
ja das weil ich also pro Monat 50 Gramm
maximal kaufen darf bedeutet das nicht
dass ich also 50 Gramm verrauchen sollte
das also ist ja auch so wenn ich ein
Restaurant zum Beispiel gehe zum ich
gehe gern zum Italiener hier also in
fensterberg da könnte ich 5 oder 6
Gerichte am Abend bestellen ich begrenze
mich am meistens auf eins und daher also
ist das eine Obergrenze die Maß hat so
dass der sag mal regelmäßige konsumente
dann noch klar kommt aber ich kann jetzt
nicht mit Begrenzungen arbeiten wo ein
regelmäßiger Konsument und sagt dann
gehe ich auf den Schwarzmarkt da ist der
stoffstärker und ich kann kaufen so viel
wie ich will wenn ich ernsthaft den
Schwarzmarkt zurückdrängen will muss ich
auch in dem Spielen mit dabei sein
welches vom Schwarzmarkt gespielt wird
ich muss dieses Spiel mitgehen können
wenn ich damit also zu geringer
Konzentration arbeite oder mit zu
geringen Mengen die abgegeben werden
können dann bin ich draußen und drängen
niemanden zurück
Herr Lauterbach sie hatten jetzt viel
über die
Kampagne gesprochen für junge Erwachsene
mir ist noch nicht ganz klar wie sie
jetzt für Kinder und Jugendliche die
Prävention stärken möchten also sie
haben jetzt den THC Gehalt angesprochen
aber gibt es noch weitere
Präventionsmaßnahmen und wir sehen die
aus also bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
ist die Präventionsmaßnahme ganz klar es
bleibt komplett illegal bleibt verboten
und was wird zusätzlich machen sind eben
Präventionsangebote für diejenigen die
ich sag mal erwischt werden und beim
problematischen Konsum werden sogar die
Jugend denn eigentlich geschaltet so
dass wir das nicht schlafen lassen aber
alles was wir jetzt machen das wird ja
nachher jeder begreifen viele Eltern
wissen gar nicht wie schädlich Cannabis
bei Kindern und Jugendlichen ist darüber
verboten gewesen nach dem Motto weil es
verboten ist wird wahrscheinlich nicht
stattfinden jeder weiß aber wie viel
konsumiert wird das Tabuthema hat dazu
geführt dass viele Erwachsene gar nicht
wissen dass zum Beispiel
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass das Kinder
Abitur macht zurückgeht abnimmt wenn es
auch häufig konsumiert und das wird ja
ein paar Monaten wird das schlicht jeder
wissen daher rechne ich auch damit dass
also eine ganz andere Aufmerksamkeit bei
den Eltern da sein wird und ich
appelliere auch bei dieser Gelegenheit
an die Eltern
kabiskonsum bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
ist sehr gefährlich das ist keine
Kleinigkeit das ist keine also Gabalier
Sache mehr und es hat zum Teil übrigens
auch nicht mit den Konzentrationen des
Cannabis zu tun die die Eltern noch aus
ihrer Kindheit kannten sondern wir
sprechen mittlerweile wirklich von ganz
anderen Dosierungen toxischen Beinen und
das kann die Kinder und Jugendlichen
stark beschädigen das will niemand von
uns ich habe selbst eine also Tochter in
diesem Alter und ich weiß dass das
bisher wirklich ein Tabuthema in den
Schule ist aber da wird er jetzt
gesprochen werden und dazu werden
übrigens auch Gelegenheiten wie die
heutige beitragen
ja Meyer Tagesspiegel Herr Minister in
dem gesetzesjahr vorgesehen dass es ein
Werbeverbot für die anbauvereine geben
soll also wie kann man sicherstellen
dass die anbauvereine in den sozialen
Medien nicht auf sich aufmerksam machen
und zweite Frage wenn Sie erlauben zu
dem Sanktionen es ist ja wenn ich das
richtig gesehen habe unter anderem
vorgesehen ein Strafmaß Freiheitsstrafen
von bis zu 3 Jahren oder Geldbußen bei
Besitz von mehr als 25 Gramm erwarten
Sie da innerhalb der Ampel kurz Edition
gerade beim Strafmaß und den Sanktionen
noch Diskussion
zunächst die Behörden müssen natürlich
prüfen ob das Werbeverbot eingehalten
wird oder nicht und die dafür
zuständigen Behörden werden ja von den
Ländern benannt somit vertraue ich da
den Ländern dass sie das streng
überprüfen werden und diese Überprüfung
ist ja auch nicht übermäßig kompliziert
muss man sagen also es wird auch so sein
dass die
anbauvereine die Werbung gar nicht
benötigen offen gesagt denn also diese
500 Mitglieder werden viele Vereine sehr
schnell haben wir bekommen ein reges
Interesse an diesem Vereinen mitgeteilt
also eine gute Nachricht wenn wir das
anders wäre müssten wir uns die Sorge
machen der Schwarzmarkt ist nicht
zurückzudringen das ist aber nicht der
Fall sondern das Interesse ist sehr groß
und daher glaube ich werden die Club
sich schnell erfüllen wenn der Club dann
500 Mitglieder hat nach die Werbung
keinen Sinn mehr ich glaube da ist in
der Praxis nicht das große Problem sein
bei den Sanktionen also wir führen immer
Gespräche in der Ampel aber ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dieses Gesetz habe ich
ja mit zahlreichen anderen Ressorts also
vorbereitet das war eine gute eine
konstruktive Debatte sie sehen ja das
also sich auch also im Vergleich zu den
letzten vorgetragenen entworfen nicht
mehr so viel geändert hat das zeigt dass
die Qualität damals schon gut gewesen
sein muss sonst hätte das Gesetz sicher
stark verändert und daher bin ich
dankbar dass Landwirtschaftsministerium
war beteiligt dass Innenministerium BMJ
natürlich also das Auswärtige Amt für
die europarechtlichen Belange der
Verkehrsminister wurde eben schon also
angesprochen
die als bmwk war mit dabei
Bundeskanzleramt wir haben im Prinzip
hier eine Arbeit gehabt an der acht
Ressorts beteiligt gewesen sind wir sind
federführend gewesen aber es war eine
gute Zusammenarbeit die ich mir auch in
anderen Bereichen für die Ampel gut
vorstellen könnte
ja Lauterbach ich wollte noch mal fragen
nach den Gefahren der
Liberalisierung die einige Kritiker
erwähnen und hat die internationale
suchtstoffkontrolle Amt im März gerade
erst eine Studie rausgegeben oder
untersucht was die Liberalisierung in
anderen Ländern
ja für Auswirkungen hatte und die kommen
zum überwiegend negativen
Auswirkungen sie haben selber erwähnt
zwei abschreckende Beispiele Niederlande
und einige US-Staaten aber die kommen
dazu dass im Schnitt die Auswirkungen
gesundheitlich negativ sein deswegen
hätte ich da ganz gerne noch mal
nachgefragt also ist Deutschland jetzt
das erste Land was es ihrer Meinung nach
richtig macht oder gibt es andere Länder
von denen sie Auffinden dass die diesen
Weg der Teil Legalisierung richtig
gegangen sind ohne den konsumen
auszuweiten ja sehr wichtige Frage in
der Tat ich habe natürlich alle
Misserfolge der Legalisierung
ausgewertet und glaube tatsächlich dass
wir aus dieser folgen viel gelernt haben
etwas zugespitzt glaube ich ist dass die
bisher beste Form der Legalisierung die
versucht wurde weil wir zum einen eben
den Schwarzmarkt tatsächlich angehen
durch diese Vereine und Genossenschaften
somit nicht den Druck der vom
Schwarzmarkt dann bleibt auf die
Konsumenten zulassen dass ein Fehler des
in den Niederlanden gemacht worden der
ist in gewisser Weise auch in den
Vereinigten Staaten gemacht worden war
dort die Kommerzialisierung an den Druck
erzeugt hat den Feuer der Schwarzmarkt
gemacht hat das nehmen wir weg da die
Idee mit den Vereinen und
Genossenschaften ist aus meiner Sicht
zentral damit das funktionieren kann
dann ist der Schwarzmarkt wirklich
zum großen Teil ausgehoben das hatte ich
für klug und ich glaube es ist auch klug
dass man das ganze sofort auch bringt
als eine Form von Gesundheitspolitik was
in den anderen Ländern nicht gemacht
worden ist also in Kanada hat man sich
da bemüht den Kinder- und Jugendschutz
und auch die Gefahren stärker zu
akzentuieren und ich bin mit dem
kanadischen Gesundheitsminister du Klo
in der Sache in Austausch und bin
angenehm angetan von der Entwicklung
eben dort dass der also Konsum 2018 war
ja die Legalisierung dass der Konsum bei
also
jungen Erwachsenen und auch bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen der immer Anstieg jetzt
nicht mehr Anstieg das heißt so jetzt
ist dort zumindest ein Plateau erreicht
und ich würde mir für uns sogar wünschen
dass wir den Anstieg nicht nur stoppen
sondern dass es uns sogar gelingt den
Konsum zurückzu Ihnen in dieser
Altersgruppe ich glaube daher um Ihre
Frage zu beantworten dass das
tatsächlich die beste bisher versuchte
Legalisierung von Cannabis überhaupt ist
da habe ich kurz nach Frank es gibt ja
bei anderen EU-Ländern die Sorge
deswegen hat sich die EU-Kommission ja
auch
zurückhaltend geäußert gehabt zu dem
ursprünglichen Entwurf dass der Konsum
überschwappt in ihre Länder also das
vielleicht können sie sagen warum das
anders als bei den Niederlanden hier in
Deutschland nicht der Fall sein sollte
denn die sorgen gibt es ja in anderen
EU-Ländern diese Sorgen werden wir
vorgetragen das sind aber keine Sorgen
die mit Nachdruck vorgetragen wurden
weil ich kann ja nur beziehen wenn ich
in Deutschland lebe sonst kann er kein
glücklich sein und somit würde das dann
nur die Clubmitglieder betreffen die in
Wirklichkeit nicht konsumieren aber also
Club Mitglied sein wollen und im Ausland
zu verkaufen bei den kleinen Männern die
dort ein einzelner pro Monat kaufen kann
macht das ja ökonomisch überhaupt keinen
Sinn ich denke Sie sich vor Sie nutzen
jetzt als nicht Konsument die 50 Gramm
die sie also
erwerben können als Clubmitglied und
verkaufen die dann das was bringt ja
keinen Gewinn von daher diese Sorge wird
der Praxis wird das keine Bedeutung
haben
wir machen hier vorne weiter
jörg hat Minister sie haben ja mal
gesagt ja und
wir sprechen über den besten
legalisierungsversuch überhaupt
zumindest wenn es nach Karl Lauterbach
geht jetzt noch mal mit meiner Kollegin
und Hauptstadt Korrespondentin
Christiane hübscher
hallo Christiane hallo Victoria ja
Christian
wir versuchen es trotzdem genau was ist
denn dein erster Eindruck dieser
Pressekonferenz jetzt würdest du
mitgehen und sagen das ist der beste
legalisierungsversuch von Cannabis
überhaupt naja was man Karl Lauterbach
zu Gute halten muss ist dass er sich
tatsächlich Gedanken offensichtlich
gemacht hat er hat ja gerade auch noch
mal jetzt zum Schluss erzählt dass er
also ähm die Versuche anderer Länder
Cannabis zu legalisieren oder Teil zu
legalisieren sich sehr genau angeschaut
hat und versucht hat daraus zu lernen
und es eben besser zu machen daher diese
Formulierung fand ich auch interessant
es ist der beste die beste Form einer
versuchten legis
Legalisierung und ich fand interessant
dass Lauterbach sofort alle Kritikpunkte
proaktiv aufgenommen hat und versucht
hat zu entkräften die es gibt also
nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Kinder und
Jugendmedizin die haben ja tatsächlich
schon seit langem und auch jetzt noch
mal zu diesem aktuellen Gesetzentwurf
sehr klar NEIN gesagt sie haben gesagt
das ist für uns überhaupt nicht okay
dass man das frei gibt ab 18 weil
nämlich dieses Gehirn eines Jugendlichen
und jungen Erwachsenen sich offenbar
tatsächlich bis Mitte 20 noch entwickelt
und ausreift und deswegen sei also in
gerade dieser Zeit Cannabiskonsum sehr
sehr gefährlich Lauterbach sagt jetzt
weiß ich stimmt aber deswegen ähm
verspreche ich mir davon sagt er dass
wir stärkeres Bewusstsein dafür finden
weil bis jetzt ist es
illegal also beschäftigen sich auch
viele Eltern und Schulen gerade z.B gar
nicht damit mit dem Thema sondern sagen
keine Ahnung was da passiert ist ja eh
verboten jetzt wird es Teil legalisiert
also müssen wir uns alle damit
beschäftigen und Lauterbach spricht also
seine Kampagne seine große aufklärungs-
und
Präventionskampagne an die stellte heute
auch parallel dazu Finanzierung unklar
können wir vielleicht später noch mal
drüber sprechen aber er versucht
jedenfalls dieses Argument gleich
aufzunehmen und zu sagen es gibt diese
gefahren aber deswegen begrenzen wir es
stark und deswegen machen wir eine
Aufklärungskampagne damit damit eben die
Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen sich
der Gefahr bewusst sehen wenn sie denn
konsumieren auch gesprochen hat er über
die Kritik die ist ja zu Hause gibt von
Polizei und von
Richter Richtern und dem Richter Bund
die eben vor allem eine ganz starke
Bürokratie befürchten eine Ansammlung
von von neuen Regeln also z.B wer soll
kontrollieren diesen 200 Meter Abstand
der gefordert wird z.B zwischen
Sportstätten und so einem Verein oder
dann zwischen der Kita und so einem
Verein sagt die Polizei sollen wir das
jetzt alles auch noch nachmessen sollen
wir auf den Balkons der deutschen
nachzählen ob sie da drei oder vier
handpflanzen für den persönlichen Bedarf
anbauen all diese Fragen dann die
Gerichte sagen eben es wird eher mehr
Streitfragen geben geben als weniger und
Lauterbach kontert das sofort und sagt
es muss für Kinder und Jugendschutz
Regeln geben ohne Regeln geht es nicht
aber er ist der Meinung das ist gut zu
machen und er sagt eben auch
wir werden die Preise werden
wahrscheinlich niedriger liegen dadurch
dass das in diesen Vereinen abgegeben
wird und eine ganz spezielle Menge nur
abgegeben wird werden die Preise
niedriger als auf dem Schwarzmarkt sein
und dadurch erhofft er sich dass der
Schwarzmarkt eben zurückgedrängt wird
ja und zu dieser Kampagne die er jetzt
so viel angesprochen hat zu der gibt es
ja auch ziemlich viel Kritik kannst du
uns noch mal zusammenfassen von wem die
kommt und warum es so viel Kritik an der
Kampagne gibt
naja ich glaube vor allem ist es ich
stößt es vielen Leuten einfach auf dass
man sagt auf der einen Seite geben wir
das jetzt frei den Cannabis Konsum ab 18
Jahren und auf der anderen Seite geben
wir sehr viel Geld aus für eine für eine
Aufklärung und Präventionskampagne an
Schulen die sich speziell an Jugendliche
richtet ähm das ist also so ein bisschen
da sehen viele so ein bisschen so ein
Widerspruch an sich drin und zum anderen
ist offensichtlich die Finanzierung
geklärt
er Lauterbach hat jetzt gerade noch mal
gesagt die Mittel für die Kampagne
stehen bereit auf der PK aus dem
Haushalt werden wir das beschreiben das
ist ja immer schön ungefähr wenn man das
so so ausdrückt ne wir werden das
beschreiben und dann sagt er noch mal
das Geld wird da sein allerdings ist es
so dass im aktuellen Haushaltsentwurf
für das gesundheitsm isterium da werden
die Mittel für die Suchtprävention
ziemlich drastisch gekürzt um Millionen
gekürzt und Lauterbach hat also schon
vorgeschlagen in den letzten Wochen dass
man da ja vielleicht die gesetzlichen
Krankenkassen einbeziehen könnte in die
Finanzierung dieser Kampagne die haben
aber sofort abgewunken der
Spitzenverband der GKV hat gleich gesagt
nein das machen wir nicht so dass ich
jetzt alles ein bisschen Fragen okay
guter Gedanke aber wo kommt die Kohle
her
ja das werden wir sehen ich gucke gerade
noch mal so ein bisschen in den Chat und
tatsächlich die meist gestellte Frage
ist gibt es den jetzt eigentlich ein
verbindliches Datum für das Go das ist
wirklich mit Abstand die meist gestellte
Frage tatsächlich hat er das bis jetzt
nicht angekündigt jedenfalls nicht in
dieser Pressekonferenz soweit wir sie
hören konnten es heißt immer wieder dass
die dass das Gesetz zum Ende des Jahres
in Kraft treten soll viele Beobachter
rechnen eher Anfang 2024 damit es gibt
auch Leute die sagen eher Ende 2024 das
war jetzt nicht zu vernehmen von Karl
Lauterbach ein konkretes Datum aber
irgendwas zwischen Ende diesen Anfang
nächsten Jahres wird wohl sein
und was sind die Hürden die jetzt bis zu
diesem finalen go noch im Weg stehen
also was für steps müssen da noch
gegangen werden tatsächlich wird sich
der Bundestag ab September damit
beschäftigen und wir haben das jetzt oft
genug gesehen gerade beim heizungsgesetz
der wird also noch viel
Diskussionsbedarf geben und womöglich
auch noch viele Änderungen an diesem
Gesetz geben durch den Bundesrat muss es
auch noch die Länder reden da
tatsächlich sehr mit das ist gerade
heute auch wieder gut zu beobachten der
Gegenwind kommt vor allem von und
unionsmitgliedern so äußern sich zum
Beispiel die CDU Innenminister aus
Bayern und aus ähm NRW und sagen für uns
ist das für uns bedeutet dieses Gesetz
der der absolute Kontrollverlust das ist
das was die befürchten herr Schuster und
Herr Royale der Gesundheitsminister aus
Bayern von der CSU Herr Holidaycheck der
hat schon gesagt ähm Herr Bundeskanzler
stocken Sie dieses Gesetz stoppen Sie
Karl Lauterbach also es ist
sehr davon auszugehen dass gerade die
CSU und CDU geführten Länder sich für
die das ja immer schon also für die ist
das Teil eines Kulturkampfes dieser
Kampf gegen Cannabis als mutmaßliche
Einstiegs Droge so bezeichnen sie das
schon seit langem dass sie sich da noch
quer stellen werden und wo möglich auch
versuchen werden die Gründung solcher
Vereine wie wir sie ja jetzt massenhaft
überall beobachten können womöglich
einfach nicht zu stoppen aber doch zu
behindern
Christiane ich bin mir sicher wir zwei
werden auf diesem Weg zum finalen go
nochmal sprechen vielen Dank dass du
meine Fragen beantwortest hast die der
Community trotz Piepen im Dorf vielen
Dank und bis bald sehr gerne tschüss
ja und eins der Themen die euch da
draußen oft am meisten interessiert wenn
es um das Thema Cannabis geht sind die
THC Grenzwerte im Straßenverkehr also
wie viel darf ich kiffen weil ich danach
noch Auto fahren will bzw was sind da
Abstände von stundentagen die ist
einzuhalten geht und über diese
Grenzwerte über die Pläne und auch die
Herausforderung spreche ich jetzt mit
Professor Stefan Tennis er ist
Vorsitzender der grenzwertkommission der
Bundesregierung und da ist er mir schon
zugeschaltet hallo Herr tönis
ähm jetzt hat ja Karl Lauterbach gerade
gesagt es muss belastbare Grenzwerte
geben ähnlich wie beim Alkohol und man
solle sich dabei auf die Studienlage
beziehen da muss ich jetzt einfach mal
zum Verständnis Fragen für mich und die
Community wie ist denn die aktuelle
Studienlage zu den Grenzwerten bei
Cannabis Konsum
die grenzwertkommission die hatte im
letzten Jahr sich sehr sehr intensiv
damit beschäftigt und das auch versucht
so zu weit zusammenzufassen und auch in
einer Publikation zu präsentieren dass
eigentlich nachvollziehbar wird dass die
Studienlage recht groß ist aber so
heterogen ist dass sich eine klare
grenzwertableitung eigentlich nicht
machen lässt insbesondere wenn man
versucht das Ganze mit Alkohol zu
vergleichen und wenn es um den
Konsumenten geht und inwieweit er von
rechtlichen Regelungen betroffen wird
muss man vielleicht auch wenn es um
alkoholgrenzwerte wenn Sie also plakativ
nennen geht vielleicht drei rechtliche
Aspekte noch mal ganz kurz
differenzieren das eine ist der
Grenzwert den wir momentan haben gilt
nur für das Straßenverkehrsgesetz und da
den Paragraph 24a
betroffen sind bekiffte Autofahrer nicht
so schön heißt auch in der Anmoderation
insbesondere dann wenn sie frauentüchtig
sind dann geht's unter Strafgesetzbuch
um den Paragrafen 316 zum Beispiel
andererseits sind aber Autofahrer die
eben ja mit Rauschmittel Wirkungen im
Straßenverkehr sich bewegen und ein
Risiko darstellen sind dann auch von
Maßnahmen betroffen die die
Führerscheinen Regelungen betreffen
damit es ein dritter Bereich der
eigentliche Thema ist und der die
Cannabis Konsumenten sicherlich umtreibt
die aktuellen Regelungen zum Grenzwert
betreffen immer den Aspekt dass es bis
jetzt illegal war das wurde gerade in
der Pressekonferenz ja auch schon
angemerkt und dass man es da relativ
einfach hatte zu sagen dass es etwas das
kann jeder selber steuern und wir wollen
jegliches Risiko im Straßenverkehr
vermeiden
dieser Grenzwert der momentan gilt diese
ein Nanogramm pro Milliliter Blutserum
ist ein Grenzwert der 1998 ähm
aufgestellt wurde die damalige Messe
Empfindlichkeit grob dargestellt hat man
muss dazu sagen dass jetzt 20 Jahre
später die nachweisempfindlichkeiten der
meisten Institute um ein vielfaches
besser sind und damit auch deutlich
geringere Konzentration festgestellt
werden diese einnahmeprogramm pro
Milliliter sollte eigentlich nur
sicherstellen dass alle Konsumenten
deutschlandweit gleich behandelt werden
wenn es um diese Sanktionen ging
man hat einen Wert genommen mit einer
Nanogramm vom Liter den man aus Studien
kannte bei dem man wusste wer ab und an
mal einen Joint raucht und
wissenschaftlich wird immer von
Gelegenheitskonsumenten locational users
in den Publikationen genannt geredet das
sind Personen die man in Studien immer
mit ungefähr einmal pro Woche Konsum
oder weniger angenommen hat und bei
denen ist nachweisbar dass eben ein
konzentrationswert von THC im Blutserum
von einem Nanogramm vom Liter durchaus
sechs bis acht Stunden nach dem letzten
Konsum unterschritten wird so dass die
die selten konsumiert haben eigentlich
nie wirklich betroffen worden sind von
diesem Grenzwerte davon falsch Aktionen
und im Endeffekt geht es beim
Straßenverkehr natürlich darum dass der
Konsument
trennt zwischen seinem Konsum und wann
er wieder Auto fährt und das ist etwas
was einerseits von Auswirkungen abhängt
andererseits natürlich auch von der
Persönlichkeit das Konsumenten
wenn man jetzt den Wert höher setzen
will dann ist die Frage auf welchen
Studien das basiert werden sollst wurde
gerade ja gesagt es soll
wissenschaftliche Studien dazu geben es
gibt zahlreiche sehr sehr viele Studien
und die Forderungen neue Daten zu
erheben bringt uns nach meiner
Einschätzung nicht wirklich viel weiter
bei sehr sehr viele Dinge schon gemacht
wurden das Problem ist nur dass die
Ergebnisse der vielen Studien teilweise
widersprüchlich sind und keinen
einheitlichen oder insbesondere kein
wissenschaftlich nachvollziehbar klar
nachvollziehbaren belegbaren Grenzwert
ableiten lassen man sieht das vielleicht
auch wenn man weltweit schaut dass die
Grenzwerte dies in verschiedensten
Ländern weltweit gibt durchaus sehr sehr
unterschiedlich sind es gibt sogar
Länder die mehrere verschiedene
Grenzwerte für verschiedene
Bereiche haben also für verschiedene
Rechtsfolgen haben
und auch in eine internationale
Kommission die im letzten Jahr getagt
hat ist nicht zu dem Punkt gekommen dass
man sich auf einen Grenzwert einigen
konnte der international von allen
Experten nachvollziehbar bezahlt wird
und das ist eben der Punkt den auch die
grenzwertkommission so publiziert hat
und ich will vielleicht kurz zu den
Studien lagen dazu sagen es gibt mehrere
Bereiche aus denen man Studiendaten hat
das eine ist dass man sich Unfälle
ansieht das heißt wenn ein Unfall
passiert war z.B ein cannabiskonsument
betroffen man kann sich angucken wie
schwer die Unfall Folgen war man kann
sich angucken ob der Cannabis Konsument
auch schuld war an dem Unfall oder nur
betroffen war und aus allen diesen
Auswertungen gibt es viele viele Studien
die jetzt auch zusammengefasst wurden
erst in den letzten Jahren woraus kommt
dass das Risiko für Unfälle eigentlich
nicht so hoch ist zumindest Alkohol was
in Deutschland ja nicht angefasst wird
und das ist nämlich das was ich im Chat
gerade so rausstellt dass unsere User
nicht so richtig verstehen wieso
Cannabis und Alkohol so unterschiedlich
behandelt wird hier sagt jemand alkohol
ist doch schädlicher als THC warum kann
ich überall und jederzeit Alkohol kaufen
der beworben wird auch neben Schulen und
Kindergärten und mich tot saufen aber
bei Gras wird alles eingeschränkt wie
ist denn da diese Vergleich der
Vergleich vom Messbarkeit von Alkohol
und THC
also das ist natürlich ein britisches
Thema aus verkehrsmedizinischer Sicht
dadurch vielleicht mal kurz anmerken
dass eine Null Promillegrenze für
Deutschland oder für die Fahrer
eigentlich das sind was wir fordern
möchten das ist eine Frage ob die
Politik damit gehen möchte bis jetzt
nicht
bei Cannabis wenn es jetzt legalisiert
wird ist das etwas schwierigere
Geschichte noch mal um die
Vergleichbarkeit mit Alkohol zu nehmen
wir haben beim alkoholwirkungen die sich
von denen das Cannabis eigentlich
deutlich unterscheiden wenn man Alkohol
vor allen Dingen eine enthemmende
Wirkung die risikovermögen
Selbstüberschätzung etc bedingen etwas
was über Cannabis in dieser Form und in
diesem Ausmaß nicht haben das ganz große
Problem wenn es um Werte geht und äh
hier um Werte im Blut sehr rum zum
Beispiel dann haben wir das ganz große
Problem dass Alkohol vom Stoffwechsel
von der Ausscheidung von der sogenannten
Pharmakokinetik komplett anders ist als
Cannabis und das Problem würde ich
vielleicht wenn ich gerade die Zeit habe
hier kurz einführen wo das richtige
gravierende Probleme mit der Beurteilung
von THC werden liegt ich hatte eben
schon gesagt der gelegentlich einmal pro
Woche Cannabis konsumiert hat relativ
geringe Konzentrationen auch schon kurz
nach dem Konsum wer das aber häufiger
betreibt und die Studienlage die ich
dazu gibt betrifft dann Konsumenten die
einmal täglich konsumieren und täglich
das heißt in Studien teilweise auch bis
zu 16 Mal pro Tag also sehr sehr häufig
ohne das weiter zu differenzieren und
bei Konsumenten die sehr sehr häufig
konsumieren täglich zum Beispiel
reichert sie sich der Wirkstoff im
Körper an und diese Anreicherung führt
dazu dass auch in den Phasen wo nicht
konsumiert wurde das kann einige Stunden
nach dem Konsum schon sein das kann aber
eben auch einen Tag oder auch mehrere
Tage nach dem letzten Konsum sein dieser
Wirkstoff THC immer noch im Blut
nachweisbar ist der dann aber nicht im
Gehirn in diesen großen Mengen mehr
vorliegt sondern vor allen Dingen aus
den Depots im Körper stammt und das Blut
abgegeben wird deswegen ist das was im
Blut nachgewiesen wird nicht
notwendigerweise etwas was direkt mit
der Konzentration im Gehirn und den
Wirkungen korreliert und deswegen ist
der konzentrationswert im Blut
schwieriger zu beurteilen als er bei
Alkoholen und es gibt auch ganz wenige
Studien die eigentlich ansatzweise eine
Korrelation mit Alkohol von THC Werten
zeigen bzw man findet beliebige Studien
die beliebige Werte Korrelation danach
nachher ausweisen da gehe ich auch noch
mal direkt rein da haben wir nämlich
gleich noch eine Frage wir haben jetzt
schon die Unterschiede ein bisschen
rausgestellt eine Frage der
Umsetzbarkeit da fragt David Schlosser
auf Facebook wie soll denn der Grenzwert
überwacht werden aktuelle Verfahren mit
Urintest werden ja teilweise positiv und
sind damit Blutprobe und verbot der
Weiterfahrt verbunden ist da eine
einfachere Überwachung geplant
das ist tatsächlich etwas was dann die
Ermittlungsbehörden sprich die Polizei
eigentlich betrifft das ist etwas was
denke ich auch in der Diskussion ist die
Urin Schnelltest sind in dem Sinne ja
eher freiwillig und sind Dinge die zwar
bei einem cannabiskonsument auch
durchaus noch recht lange positiv sein
können maßgeblich für Sanktion sie ist
immer momentan die Blutprobe
es gibt andere vortestergebnisse und
andere vortestmöglichkeiten aber das ist
etwas das glaube ich noch in der
Diskussion ist jemand damit weiter
umgeht und die drogenerkennung im
Straßenverkehr ist etwas was er
natürlich nicht nur über solche Vortest
läuft sondern auch über den Eindruck den
der der Polizist dann beispielsweise von
dem Fahrrad hat
und zum Schluss habe ich noch eine Frage
zu dem weiteren politischen Vorgehen es
gab ja heute die Meldung und die
Sprecherin des Verkehrsministeriums
bestätigt dass jetzt auch das
Verkehrsminister Wissing eine eigene
Arbeitsgruppe aus Fachleuten für diesen
Cannabis Grenzwert einsetzen will
parallel zu der grenzwertkommission zu
der auch sie gehören die sich ja uneinig
war wie bewerten sie das
ähm
ich persönlich würde sagen dass die
grenzwertkommission besetzt ist
Mitgliedern die sich zumindest aus ihrer
institutionellen Befassung sehr gut mit
Konzentrationen im Straßenverkehr oder
von Konsumenten und auch mit den
Ausfallserscheinungen auskennen
man kann natürlich noch gerne weitere
Kommissionen dazu nehmen nur ich
persönlich glaube dass die
wissenschaftliche Lage und die Datenlage
so breit ist dass man wenn man das
möchte mit wissenschaftlichen Daten
jeden beliebigen Grenzwert fast
vertreten könnte es ist die Frage welche
Studien man dazu auswählt und es hat
auch was damit zu tun welchen
Risikobereich man durch die Regelung
nachher haben möchte
vielleicht muss man ganz plakativ zu
sagen ich hatte eben ja schon gesagt
chronischer Konsum also häufiges
konsumieren für zur Anreicherung und
wenn jetzt kann er das legalisiert wird
werden die Leute erwartungsgemäß
zumindest aus meiner Sicht persönlich
mehr konsumieren vielleicht oder
häufiger und dann werden sich mehr
Verwandten irgendwie dann auch mehr
angereichert haben wenn man das zulässt
dann wird man wenn man einen sehr
niedrigen Grenzwert ansetzt Leute
sanktionieren also Konsumenten
sanktionieren die vielleicht nicht
berauscht sind aber die eben durchaus
ein entsprechenden thc-residualwert noch
haben andererseits wenn man eine Wert
höher setzt dann wird man denjenigen die
Joint geraucht haben bekifft ins Auto
steigen und dann möglicherweise
zufälligerweise drunter liegen die wird
man nicht sanktionieren im Sinne von dem
Schuss vor dem Buch und das ist eine
Frage die sich natürlich auf die
Verkehrssicherheit und auch Führerschein
Maßnahmen auswirkt deswegen ist es im
Endeffekt eine politische Entscheidung
welche Gruppe von Personen man hier
benachteiligen will oder was man in den
Fokus trifft sie Verkehrssicherheit
damit wäre man dann aber auch bei dem
Punkt dass ähm die Leute die häufiger
konsumieren dann wahrscheinlich häufiger
sanktioniert werden auch wenn sie nicht
akut gekifft haben oder man setzt den
Grenzwert höher und dann hat man eben
das Problem dass man Leute die akut
braucht sind nicht sanktioniert
vielen Dank für Ihre Antworten wir
nehmen auf jeden Fall mit dass das
wissenschaftlich schwierig einzuschätzen
ist und deswegen vor allem eine
politische Frage vielen Dank
ja und jetzt zum Schluss gucken wir noch
mal auf die rechtliche Perspektive zu
diesem Thema und zwar noch mal mit ZDF
Rechtsexperten Jan Henrich der mit mir
im Studio steht haiern hallo was ist
denn deine Einschätzung wir haben eben
gehört die wissenschaftlichen
Einschätzung zu diesen Grenzwerten sind
nicht so ganz eindeutig es ist auch eine
politische Frage wie sieht denn die
rechtliche Perspektive auf dieses Thema
aus also die rechtliche Perspektive nach
dem aktuellen Status wo ist
vergleichsweise streng ähm im Besonderen
Vergleich zu Alkohol man hat hier eine
Regelung die selbst wenn nur ein
Nachweis passieren kann
das eben THC im Blut nachgewiesen werden
kann dann ist das zumindest mal eine
Ordnungswidrigkeit in der Regel fallen
da fällt ein Bußgeld von 500 € an dazu
kommt noch einen Monat Fahrverbot und
was tatsächlich für viele Betroffenen
dann schwer wiegt das eine MPU
angeordnet werden kann eine medizinisch
psychologische Untersuchung und die kann
sehr viel Zeit und Geld kosten und dazu
kommt das tatsächlich auch noch auch
wenn kein Cannabiskonsum im Zusammenhang
mit einer Autofahrt steht bei
regelmäßigen Konsumenten auch generell
die Fahrerlaubnis aberkannt werden kann
das heißt dass man dort auch wenn man
nicht bekifft Auto fährt
gegebenenfalls einen Führerschein seine
Fahrerlaubnis verlieren kann und auch
was viele nicht wissen selbst die
Begriff der Fahrt auf einem E-Scooter
die kann dazu führen dass man seinen
KFZ-Führerschein auch verliert das wird
oft unterschätzt also die Regeln sind
tatsächlich sehr streng was kann er bis
im Straßenverkehr angeht und andere
Länder sind da tatsächlich weiter
teilweise gibt es Länder die Grenzwerte
haben die um ein zehnfaches höher liegen
als in Deutschland krass ja wir haben
eben gehört dass es eben auch daran
liegt dass man den äh in die Wirkung von
Alkohol sehr viel einfacher und
allgemeiner messen kann als die
von THC wir haben zu dem Thema hier ein
paar Fragen aus der Community die ich
mal an dich weiterleiten würde hier
fragt jemand auf Youtube mit den drei
dann legalen Pflanzen kriegt man ja viel
mehr als 50 Gramm raus wer soll das
eigentlich kontrollieren das ist eine
sehr gute Frage das ist auch eine Frage
die in einer der Stellungnahmen vom
deutschen handverband zu dem
Gesetzesentwurf aufgeworfen wurde weil
natürlich
zumindest mal die theoretisch
Möglichkeit besteht dass der Anbau zwar
dann legal ist aber sobald man erntet
man über die Freigrenze kommt und sich
dann theoretisch sogar strafbar machen
kann ich gehe mal davon aus dass sind
Dinge die noch geklärt werden gerade im
Gesetzgebungsprozess von daher wird
damit Sicherheit Lösungen geben man
müsste auch noch mal vielleicht ins
Kleingedruckte rein und schauen
vielleicht gibt's ja auch schon was aber
ja das ist im Moment noch eine offene
Frage
hier fragen auch mehrere Leute noch mal
nach der EU Ebene auf Youtube fragt Ecke
wie EU-konform ist denn lauter was
Drogen Reform und generell schwört hier
so ein bisschen die Frage rum ob das ob
die EU das Gesetz noch kippen könnte
also bei diesem ersten Schritt bei der
endkriminalisierung von Privatkonsum bei
der Entkriminalisierung von privatem
kleinstanbau ist es sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass sie EU das Kippen
kann weil es eben diese Ausnahmeregelung
für
Privatkonsum gibt im europäischen Recht
die Länder treffen können was die zweite
Säule was den Verkauf angeht in
modellstädten wie das mal angedacht war
in dem Eckpunktepapier von April da wird
es tatsächlich schwieriger und deswegen
wird dieser Teil auch noch mal nach
Brüssel gegeben zur Überprüfung ob sich
dann eine Lösung finden lässt und
natürlich die Bundesregierung hat auch
angekündigt dass sie sich in Brüssel
dafür einsetzen will dass der Rahmen
sozusagen zumindest
eventuell irgendwann noch mal neu
gefasst oder liberalisiert wird
Frage aus dem direktem Leben quasi das
merkt man eh dass ich da ganz viele
Leute gerade Fragen stellen die glaube
ich sehr eng an ihrer Lebensrealität
sind die vielleicht aktuell noch gar
nicht so richtig ausformuliert oder mit
gedacht äh sind die fragt jemand auf
Youtube wie ist denn die Regel für den
Konsum auf einem Balkon in der Nähe von
Schulen oder Kindergärten
ja das ist auch eine gute Frage das ist
mit sicherheitlich auch mit Sicherheit
auch eine Frage mit der sich Gerichte
früher oder später dann
auseinandersetzen müssen normalerweise
in einem bisherigen Entwurf sieht sieht
es so aus dass der öffentliche Konsum in
diesen Bereichen in diesen 200 Meter
Bandgrenzen rund um schulenkindergärten
diesen Cannabis Clubs
dass das dort verboten ist
wie es mit dem privaten Konsum in den
eigenen verwenden aussieht das ist noch
mal eine andere Sache und da zählt
normalerweise der Balkon dazu aber wie
gesagt auch eine Frage die noch nicht
abschließen geklärt ist ja du hast
gerade gesagt das ist dann Frage der
Gerichte wir haben davor gehört ja da
muss dann vielleicht die Polizei waren
eigentlich sollte dieses Gesetz ja den
Behörden die Arbeit vereinfachen und sie
entlasten klingt das aktuell so
es wird zumindest mal stark in Frage
gestellt also das die Zahlen die die
Bundesregierung hier
angesetzt hat in dem Gesetz des Entwurf
findet sich die Zahl des Kosten für die
Strafverfolgung und für Gerichtsprozesse
in Höhe von einer Milliarde Euro
jährlich eingespart werden sollen wenn
man diese Verfolgung von Cannabis
kleinstkriminalität eben sich dann
sparen kann und da geht es sowohl von
Seiten der Polizei Gewerkschaften als
auch von Seiten des deutschen Richter
bundessta starke Zweifel dass das der
Fall sein wird der Punkt ist das ist das
was der Deutsche Richterbund anbringt
dass gerade diese
Verfolgung von Besitz mit kleineren
Mengen dass die Verfolgung von von dem
kleinen Anbau auf dem Balkon mit drei
Pflanzen dass das derzeit nicht die
großen Kapazitäten bindet ohnehin schon
nicht sondern dass eben wirklich die
großen Kosten in der Verfolgung von von
Straftaten rund um Cannabis eben bei der
Verfolgung von grenzüberschreitender
großkriminalität stattfindet und die
lässt sich zumindest so der Richter Bund
damit eben nicht einsparen
ja wir sehen da ist noch ziemlich viel
unklar ich finde du hast uns trotzdem
auf jeden Fall mal weitergeholfen vielen
Dank gern dass du unsere Fragen
beantwortet hast ja und ich finde es ist
ziemlich klar jetzt nach dieser knappen
Stunde die wir uns mit dem Thema befasst
haben und dass dieses ehemalige
Prestigeprojekt der Ampel Koalition so
ein bisschen zu einem ziemlich komplexen
Sorgenkind geworden ist da sind ganz
viele Fragen noch offen gibt viele
verschiedene Kritik daran wir haben euch
mal gefragt in der Community wie ihr
eigentlich zu dieser Legalisierung steht
ich zeige euch mal die Umfrageergebnisse
die sprechen so ein bisschen für sich
und zwar haben wir ja im Community Tab
gefragt ob Cannabis legalisiert werden
sollte oder nein ich habe jetzt einfach
mal ja geklickt und die Ergebnisse zu
sehen und ihr seid da als Community
ziemlich zweigeteilt 50% stimmt ja 50 %
Stimmen für nein
wie ist mit diesem Gesetz weitergeht wir
werden auf jeden Fall weiter für euch
darüber berichten und wenn ihr jetzt
nach wir haben schon immer noch Lust
habt euch mit dem Thema
auseinanderzusetzen dann empfehle ich
euch noch
diese interaktive Story da haben wir
euch den Link in die Infobox gepackt da
könnt ihr euch einfach mal so ein
bisschen durch swipen wie wirkt
eigentlich Cannabis was sind die
verschiedenen Bestandteile der Pflanze
da könnt ihr euch Einhorn ein bisschen
durchklicken wenn euch das Thema
weiterhin interessiert vielen Dank dass
ihr bis jetzt dran geblieben seid danke
für eure Fragen und Antworten und bis
zum nächsten Mal